♪♪
YOU'VE SEEN IT ON BOBA FETT.
YOU'VE SEEN IT ON THE ROCKETEER.
IT'S THE JETPACK --
THE HOLY GRAIL
OF FUTURISTIC TRANSPORTATION.
THE IDEA OF JUST BEING ABLE
TO STRAP ON A PACK
AND FLY ANYWHERE
YOU WANT TO GO --
HOW ABOUT THAT
FOR BEATING TRAFFIC?
Narrator: TODAY, YOU WILL
BE BUILDING A JB-9 JETPACK,
THE ONLY TRUE JETPACK
IN OPERATION IN THE WORLD.
I THOUGHT THIS WAS NOT A THING
THAT HAD BEEN
PROPERLY INVENTED YET.
THIS EXISTS?
Narrator: YOU WILL NEED
TWO JET TURBINE ENGINES,
THROTTLE AND STEERING
HAND CONTROLS,
A KEROSENE FUEL TANK,
A CARBON-FIBER MOLDED HARNESS,
AND A HATRED
OF SITTING IN TRAFFIC.
LET'S GET STARTED.
STEP ONE -- NECESSITY IS
THE MOTHER OF INVENTION.
SO FIRST, BECOME FED UP
WITH EXISTING
PERSONAL-FLIGHT TECHNOLOGY.
IN THE PAST, JETPACKS WERE
MORE LIKE ROCKETPACKS,
AND THEY USED A LOT OF VERY
HEAVY AND VERY EXPENSIVE FUEL,
AND THEY COULD RUN OUT
OF THIS FUEL
IN AS SHORT AS 30 SECONDS,
AND IT WASN'T REALLY
GOOD FOR ANYTHING
BESIDES MAYBE
A DEMONSTRATION AT THE OLYMPICS
OR AN APPEARANCE
IN A JAMES BOND FILM.
Narrator:
IF YOU WANT TO FLY LIKE THIS
FOR MORE THAN 30 SECONDS,
YOU NEED TO FIND A WAY
TO GENERATE DOWNWARD THRUST
FOR A LONGER PERIOD OF TIME.
STEP TWO -- DEVELOP THE
PERFECT-SIZED TURBINE ENGINE.
YOU'VE GOT A LOT
OF DIFFERENT-SIZED ENGINES.
THERE'S HUGE JET ENGINES
TO POWER BIG 747s,
AND SMALL ONES
FOR LITTLE HOBBY APPLICATIONS.
WHAT WE NEED FOR A JETPACK
IS ONE JUST EXACTLY RIGHT-SIZED
TO CARRY THE WEIGHT OF A HUMAN.
STEP THREE -- DESIGN A WAY
TO KEEP YOURSELF SAFELY ATTACHED
TO YOUR JETPACK.
CONSTRUCT A HARNESS FROM
STATE-OF-THE-ART CARBON FIBER,
ATTACHING NYLON STRAPS,
ALUMINUM BUCKLES,
AND A LAYER OF FOAM FOR COMFORT.
STEP FOUR -- IT'S TIME TO ATTACH
ALL YOUR COMPONENTS TOGETHER.
CONSTRUCT TWO HANDLES
WITH ARMS, "A,"
OUT OF LIGHTWEIGHT ALUMINUM,
AND CONNECT
TO BOTH ENGINES, "B,"
VIA TWO-INCH ALUMINUM TUBES.
CONNECT YOUR ENGINE AND ARMS
TO YOUR HARNESS
WITH A ROD END PLACED JUST
BEHIND THE NECK OF THE HARNESS.
A ROD END IS A JOINT THAT CAN
ARTICULATE IN ANY DIRECTION.
IT'S SORT OF LIKE YOUR SHOULDER.
YOU HAVE A BALL AND YOU HAVE
A SOCKET THAT GOES ON TOP OF IT,
AND THE SOCKET CAN MOVE
IN ANY DIRECTION YOU NEED.
Narrator: STEP FIVE --
NOW ALL YOU NEED IS THE ABILITY
TO CONTROL YOUR PACK.
ADD A THROTTLE CONTROL
ON THE RIGHT-HAND GRIP
TO FEED MORE FUEL
TO YOUR ENGINES...
THE THROTTLE HANDLE IS USED
TO CONTROL THE THRUST
COMING OUT OF THE JETS.
YOU GO FASTER OR HIGHER
WHEN YOU TURN THE HANDLE,
OR THROTTLE, FORWARD.
BUT IF SOMETHING HAPPENS,
YOU TURN IT BACK,
IT'LL SLOW YOU DOWN.
Narrator: STEP SIX --
ADD A FUEL TANK,
AND YOU'LL BE READY TO SOAR.
Bodden: I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S GONNA BE A GREAT FUTURE
WHEN WE ALL HAVE JETPACKS.
I MEAN, HOW MUCH IS
JETPACK INSURANCE GONNA COST?